Елітні Hugo Boss, Moschino, Dolce&Gabbana, більш масові Zara чи Orsay і чимало інших знаних брендів давно шиють одяг в Україні.
Але придбати його можна лише в Європі. В українських крамницях переважає продукція з Китаю, Бангладеш і Туреччини.
DW вирішила з'ясувати, чому українським фабрикам невигідно продавати Made in Ukraine в Україні.
Для цього рушаємо на Чернігівську швейну фабрику "Елегант", яка виготовляє одяг для європейських брендів.
Тут, в експериментальному цехУ роблять, так би мовити, пробу пера - шиють пробний зразок для потенційного замовника.
Бренд надсилає модель, а фабрика має показати, що здатна це виготовити.
Документи вивчаємо, складаємо технологічну послідовність, прошиваємо зразки, рахуємо норми, листуємося з іноземними фірмами.
Одним словом, роботи в нас багато.
Європейці також надсилають своїх представників на перевірку виробництва.
Адже працюють лише з тими фабриками, яким довіряють, каже директорка чернігівського підприємства.
Без плану, без знайомства з тобою не почнуть працювати. Тобто репутація для них - усе.
Якщо замовлення погодили, фабрика отримує європейські лекала, тканину, фурнітуру.
Це так звана давальницька схема - коли сировину дає замовник.
За такою схемою тут шиють одяг бренди з Польщі, Франції, Швеції, Німеччини.
У них уже нема свого виробництва. І майже ніколи не було. Можливо, було в 30-40 роках, але на сьогодні немає. І головне - у них немає робочого персоналу.
Кожна швачка відповідає за свою деталь. За день відшивають сотні жакетів, брюк, пальт.
Згодом їх продаватимуть у магазинах німецьких торгових марок Orsay, Comma, S.Oliver, Walbusch.
На всіх речах - позначка Made in Ukraine. А ще - цінник, визначений брендом.
Співробітниці фабрики в середньому заробляють 9 тисяч гривень на місяць. Для обласного центру це немало.
Але пошитих власними руками речей чернігівчанкам на свою зарплату не купити.
Наші вироби радше за кордоном купуються. Можливо, тому що там люди більшу зарплату отримують.
У нас в Україні люди ще не настільки платоспроможні, щоб придбати те, що тут виготовляється.
Українцям доводиться купувати товари тих самих брендів, але виробництва Китаю чи Бангладеш.
Якість гірша, але й ціна нижча. Або ж - носити секонд-хенд. Україна - одна з лідерів у світі за обсягами імпорту ношеного одягу.
З 2014 року з'явилося чимало українських брендів.
Але незначні обсяги й велике податкове навантаження роблять ціну на їхню продукцію непідйомною для пересічного українця.
Нашим підприємствам, виробникам своїх брендів і дизайнерам дуже проблематично бути конкурентними поряд з іноземними брендами,
бути представленими з ними поряд, тому що держава не підтримує їхню присутність ніякими механізмами, які могли б надати конкуренцію,
і щоб для споживачів вони були також доступні.
Швейним фабрикам вигідно працювати з Європою. Стабільні замовлення, великі обсяги.
На фабриці в Корсунь-Шевченківському шиють спецодяг, зокрема для австрійських пожежників.
У керівництві кажуть: з українською державою їм працювати немає сенсу.
Ціна по Україні, ми працювали на нашому ринку, не покриває наших затрат.
Набагато вигідніше працювати з Європою, бо там платять краще, ніж в Україні.
У відсотках порівняти - це один до двох може навіть.
Нині 80 відсотків усього українського легпрому працює за давальницькою схемою на Європу і США.
У 90-х такий метод утримав галузь на плаву, а зараз виходить замкнене коло:
що більше фабрик шиють з чужої сировини, то менше тканин, ниток, фурнітури виробляють в Україні.
Україна в першу чергу втрачає те, що тут не створюється висока додана вартість продукції.
Це коли з пряжі виготовляється тканина на текстильному виробництві, з усім технологічним процесом від ткацтва до готової тканини,
потім ця тканина відшивається в Україні і тоді продається готовий продукт, виготовлений в Україні.
Товари з високою доданою вартістю - це в першу чергу стабільна економіка і державне забезпечення.
З іншого боку, іноземні замовлення дають Україні робочі місця.
Hugo Boss, Moschino, Dolce&Gabbana, Zara й десятки відомих фірм цінують українську якість і географічну близькість.
Україна є середньою ціною між азіатською і європейською, тому Європі дуже вигідно розташовувати свої виробничі потужності саме в Україні,
бо Україна розташована найближче до країн Європи, логістика займає найменше часу, ну і якість відповідна.
Близькість до Європи незабаром може стати однією з найбільших переваг української продукції, переконані на швейних підприємствах.
Через пандемію почалася логістична криза. Транспорт, особливо морський, здорожчав.
Західним брендам тепер вигідніше замовляти пошиття одягу не в Азії, а в Україні.
Китай був конкурентом України. Але після подій 19-го року по ціні став неконкурентним, дорожчим.
З Білоруссю добре працювали, але з нею зараз напружені відносини.
З Росією добре працювали, але з нею теж напружені відносини.
У Литві, Латвії майже не лишилося виробництва. Болгарія, Румунія - та ж історія.
Тобто Україна ще зберегла острівець легкої промисловості на пострадянському просторі і, я б навіть сказала, має перспективу для Європи.
На чернігівській фабриці чекають ще більше замовлень з Європи й готові за них братися.
Роботою з іноземними брендами задоволені.
Утім, співробітниці все ж таки сподіваються колись побачити свої речі і в українських крамницях.
Я думаю, ми в майбутньому будемо шити для України.
Якщо в нас буде зростати рівень життя, будемо в Європі, то люди будуть купувати й наше, українське.
Українська легка промисловість - це дві з половиною тисячі підприємств і 120 тисяч робочих місць.
За даними "Укрлегпрому", через пандемію кожен шостий працівник втратив роботу.
За словами фахівців, нині головне для галузі - зберегти робочі місця й домогтися умов,
вигідних не лише європейцям, а й українським працівникам.